Seventy-one years ago, on a bright cloudless morning,...
...death fell from the sky and the world was changed.
A flash of light and a wall of fire destroyed a city...
...and demonstrated that mankind possessed the means to destroy itself.
Why do we come to this place, to Hiroshima?
We come to ponder a terrible force unleashed in a not-so-distant past.
We come to mourn the dead,...
...including over 100,000 Japanese men, women and children,...
...thousands of Koreans, a dozen Americans held prisoner.
Their souls speak to us.
They ask us to look inward,...
...to take stock of who we are and what we might become.
Those who died, they are like us.
Ordinary people understand this, I think.
They do not want more war.
They would rather that the wonders of science be focused on improving life...
...and not eliminating it.
When the choices made by nations,...
...when the choices made by leaders reflect this simple wisdom,...
...then the lesson of Hiroshima is done.